if you lived in the valley for a long
time you know how brutal the summers can
be
but what's really something to pay
attention to is the prolonged amount of
dangerous heat that you can take
on a toll on any of us and even people
who live in hot climates it does not
make us immune to hot climates
dr dominic martinello chief medical
officer at southern hills hospital says
each summer
they treat heat related illnesses and
injuries
the human body can only regulate within
a certain range with all the events over
the weekend there were mild to moderate
cases reported
the biggest thing for us is dehydration
so we're fortunate that most people
start to seek help before that heat
stroke
dr adrian gomez over at mountain view
hospital says patients they saw were
also
not drinking enough water people were
listening to the recommendations we
didn't have very many
heat strokes or heat exhaustion
definitely dehydration
and according to dr jay coats at sunrise
hospital watch for burns to your body
that walk to the pool can bring your
feet and door handles can burn your
hands
i've had at least two burns this year
already that were
second degree burns just from sunburn
a reminder avoid the hottest times of
the day that is from 2 to 6 p.m now
according to the clark county fire
department
from july 7 to july 11 they responded to
85 incidents categorized as
heat cold exposure related live in the
studio sally jaramillo 8 news now